[موسيقى]
هناك تخوف في واشنطن من ان الصين اذا ما
قامت ببناء منشات في الخليج فهذه المنشات
الصينيه قد تؤثر على امن القوات الامريكيه
فالامريكيون قلقون جدا من علم الاستخبارات
الصينيه بالمعلومات حول القدرات العسكريه
المتقدمه التي نزودها للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه او الى الامارات العربيه المتحده
وقبل عامين عبرت امريكا عن قلقها لابو ظبي
حول منشاه عسكريه صينيه كانت ستتمكن من
الحصول على معلومات استخباراتيه حول طائره
امريكيه متقدمه كانت تفكر في بيعها
للامارات العربيه المتحده
هناك قلق من شركائنا بين دول الخليج حول
التزام امريكا خاصه بعد الهجوم على بقيق
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه عام 2019
وهذا القلق الخليجي مفهوم بشكل كامل
ولكنني اعتقد اننا يجب ان ندرك ان اداره
بايدن تختلف عن اداره ترامب حيث تتبع
اداره بايد المقاربه تقليديه في السياسه
الخارجيه الامريكيه وبخلاف اداره ترامب
فان اداره بايدن تو الاهتماما بالغا
للاقتصاد الدولي وبالتالي طول اهتماما
خاصا باسواق الطاقه كما لم تفعل اداره
ترامب ابدا